[Musique]
bonjour annick cojean ou jouent
journaliste grand reporter au monde et
vous publier ce livre une nouvelle série
d'entretiens regroupés autour du titre
nous ne serions pas arrivés là si trois
points de suspension elle s'appelle
entre autres gisèle halimi barbara
hendricks isabelle carré emma thompson
marjane satrapi impossible de citer tous
les noms des femmes dont la voix porte
et qui se raconte annick cojean pour
commencer et puisque nous sommes servis
par l'actualité je vais vous montrer une
image qui va arriver dans quelques
secondes est ce que cette personne que
nous allons voir à l'image pourrait
figurer dans votre livre
va arriver elle va arriver elle va
arriver j'ai confiance
c'est d'elle que nous parlait
assure qu'elle pourrait être dans mon
livre se trouve qu'on a on a une règle
actuellement au monde puisque son nez
des interviews que j'ai fait à l'origine
pour le monde de ne pas prendre les
personnes du gouvernement
si tout nouveau mais je vous assure
qu'il y en a plusieurs qui m'intéressent
bougrement et la bête bornes serait
l'une des premières parce que je trouve
qu'elle a une personnalité sur laquelle
j'ai envie de savoir énormément de
choses son enfance certainement
compliqué de ce père parti très jeune ce
père d'origine juive je pense que toutes
les sept 7 courses d'obstacles ont été
pour elle les grandes écoles de la
république et les plus difficiles ya dû
avoir un moteur il ya du havre une
ambition terrible terrible de quoi de
pouvoir de réparer quelque chose de de
satisfaire un papa qui n'était plus là
de donner aussi rendre le sourire à sa
mère je sais pas il ya beaucoup
d'éléments personnels qui auraient pu
figurer effectivement dans son livre on
rappelle qu'au tout début elle a dédié
son arrivée à matignon à toutes les
petites filles 33 voix donc deux femmes
impossible je les dis de citer tous les
noms quels ont été les principaux
critères de choix année cochon que tu
esthétique parfois l'actualité parce que
ça rend les gens plus disponibles
lorsqu'ils sortent à
roman lorsqu'il ya un gars concert à
disque une pièce de théâtre ou quelque
chose qui me plaît particulièrement
dense qu'elle dans l'heure actuelle leur
actualité personnelle et puis souvent
mon attrait pour le rencontrer j'avais
envie de rencontrer pleuriez à steinen
qui sans doute là la féministe la plus
iconique de toute l'amérique du nord et
donc du monde je dirais d'une certaine
façon parce qu'elle a porté trop des
combats gisèle halimi c'est vrai que là
pour le coup elle n'avait pas une
actualité mais elle n'avait pas parlé
depuis dix ans et avait tellement envie
de savoir l'itinéraire de cette femme
qui a tellement le fait pour les femmes
françaises pour l'avortement pour
l'algérie également contre la torture et
puis sur les lois sur le viol était
terrasse sur la sur la parité c'est
vraiment là aussi un des plus grands
symboles je pense pour les femmes du 20e
siècle et il les générations futures et
puis et puis on a tellement d'autres
tirages et marjane satrapi qui a
tellement créer sa sa patte particulière
dans le cas river qui arrivé d'iran
j'aime bien qu'elle arrive aussi d'autre
part alors ce que ce que j'ai relevé par
veut de moi nico je sais que dans
l'ensemble 1 ce sont des stars dans
leurs demandes des célébrités choses
mais pas de citoyen ordinaire si l'on
peut dire on pense évidemment à toutes
ces femmes peut-être qu'ils sont
inspirantes mais qui n'ont peut-être pas
la faveur des projecteurs c'était un
choix aussi où vous avez wee b / j'aime
bien de temps en temps qu'il y ait
d'autres personnes dont on ne situe pas
immédiatement le là puisque ma question
c'est toujours je ne serais pas arrivé
là si donc j'essaie de faire en sorte
que la plupart du temps on les situe
mais quelquefois
j'aille là amadou j'ai
eu des lycéens oui la guerre et cette
africaine qui vraiment s'est imposé dans
le monde de la littérature est de plus
en plus populaire est un vrai symbole je
pense pour les petites filles qui savent
qu effectivement qu écrire peut vous
emmener très très loin qui parle des
mariages forcés qui parle des
difficultés des femmes delà de la
polygamie etc je pense que c'est très
important qu'on entende sa également je
pense que
y'en a d'autres peut être aussi moins
connue dans le monde de vente de la
chanson je paye est l'or puisque vous
parlez de du monde de la chanson le
fonds avait tendu la perche je la prends
les entretiens commencent tous par je ne
serais pas arrivé là si les réponses
sont plus ou moins longues après et puis
comme ça au détour d'un échange on tombe
sur anne sylvestre a requis 10 et je ne
serais pas arrivée là tu si si je
n'avais pas eu ce n'est c'est la seule
phrase que je répond qu'est-ce qui la
vote n'est alors marqué me dis bah il
était pas vrai normes quand j'ai
commencé tout jeune fille on me disait
il faut le changer et ce n'est ça n'est
pas possible pas faire une carrière vous
vous écrirez peut-être mais en tout cas
vous ne serez jamais devant les écrans
ni sur une scène rien que ça sall a
aiguillonné salut a envie d'aller plus
loin vous n'aimez pas mon mba vous le
verrez et à partir de là je crois à la
fois ce n'est révélé son caractère ce
n'est a été comme un déclencheur aussi
pour vous ne m'aimez pas et vous
arrivera un jour à mai mais parce que je
m'imposerai ce n'était aussi celui de
son père son père avec laquelle elle
avait une histoire compliquée ce père
qui avait été collaborateur pendant la
guerre mis en prison juste après la
guerre
retrouvez en allemagne mais en prison
qu'elle chez kia faro auprès duquel elle
est allée rendre visite pendant dix ans
petite fille sous l'opprobre évidemment
général et moqueries de ses camarades
étaient terra ce père qui avait disparu
quand elle avait entre cinq et dix ans
qu'elle avait le temps d'aimer et
qu'elle n'a pas renier même si ça a été
une croix pendant le reste de sa
carrière donc voilà ça dit beaucoup de
choses années et beaucoup de comme ça de
détail peuvent révéler une vie vous avez
fait nico gens des femmes votre sujet de
prédilection
parce qu'il ya beaucoup beaucoup de
textes de vous soit des articles tout
vrai livre notamment consacré à simone
veil qu'est ce que cette spécialisation
autour des femmes vous a appris dans
votre métier de journaliste écoutez
c'était pas une spécialisation du tout
au départ simplement en voyageant dans
nombreux pays me suis rendu compte à
quel point encore même pour ma
génération
c'était juste une malédiction de naître
femme dans la plupart des pays du monde
en voyageant pakistan en afghanistan
dans les pays du maghreb dans beaucoup
d'autres pays je me rendais compte je
pouvais le ressentir m'a même dans mon
pays mais quand même à quel point
évidemment ça voulait dire inégalités ça
voulait dire différence de traitement ça
voulait dire moins d'éducation moins de
nourriture ça voulait dire est de marier
sans son consentement ça voulait dire
probablement être battu peut-être
circoncis et cetera et cetera donc ça
donne envie de leur de les faire parler
ça donne envie de braquer les coups de
projecteur sur eux sur elle je devrais
dire est que lorsque je pars en
reportage quel que soit le sujet de mon
reportage parce que non ce n'est pas une
spécialité mais quand je vais à enquêter
dans différents pays systématiquement
jan glent je tourne la caméra mois qui
suit la presse écrite mais je tourne la
caméra vers les femmes et elles
vivent je vais vous montrer une image
qui va arriver
on a été la chercher assez loin je vous
propose qu'on la regarde on se retrouve
dans quelques secondes annick cojean
quand vous portez ça vous ne pouvez même
pas respirer même s'il menace de me
pendre je ne porterai pas la burqa
la burqa n'est pas notre job ce n'est
pas notre identité
ce que je porte pour moi c'est le hidjab
ils m'ont arrêté plusieurs fois à cause
de ma tenue en me disant ne sortait pas
comme ça c'est arrivé tellement de fois
mais je n'accepte pas de couvrir mon
visage ou de montrer que mes yeux parce
que je ne pense pas qu allah soit aussi
cruel images tournées vous l'aurez
reconnu
signé de notre correspondante sonia
ghezali au masque c'est afghanes peuvent
s'en sortir ah c'était pouvant taf
peuvent se sortir peut-être avec la
solidarité internationale parce que
c'est pas liban les talibans qui vont
changer d'avis évidemment en est qui
sont plus ou moins progressiste comme on
a eu l'air de le penser à un moment
donné quelle propagande épouvantable ils
ont fait d'ailleurs en disant qu'ils
avaient échangé au fait quelques signes
à l'égard de l'occident
la seule façon c'est effectivement nous
soyons intraitables sur ce sujet que ce
soit une condition sinequanone pour leur
donner des aides et pour les considérer
comme des interlocuteurs la libération
des femmes le respect à l'égard des
femmes c'est un pays épouvante amant il
va revenir justement quand on a vu les
conditions avec et les américains sont
partis d'afghanistan est ce qu'ils ont
dit que si on pense que ces femmes ont
été abandonnés dans le vrai oui oui
vraiment et quand je vois parfois des
délégations occidentales
qui sont bien obligés d'aller parler à
l'ipp talibans parce que il faut
évidemment parlé avec les ennemis ou
avec nos adversaires et comme elle ne
pas les considérer comme ça et bien on
doit systématiquement avoir dans les
délégations des femmes évidemment pour
leur montrer que oui nous sommes des
interlocutrices et que la société les
changements de société ne peuvent pas se
faire sans les femmes ils sont fous de
se priver de leur talent ils sont fous
de ne pas leur leur octroyer les droits
et de ne pas reconnaître l'égalité c'est
épouvantable je pense que si je
proprement vivable c'est la moitié de la
population quand on essaie d'imaginer
j'entends parfois des gens dire ça va
pas si mal en afghanistan mais si bien
sûr c'est totalement chaotique c'est la
misère c'est le risque de la fin c'est
la pauvreté absolue c'est le manque de
pita les terrains etc une personne sur
deux qui est méprisé mis sur le côté
abandonné considéré comme un animal un
écho jean 33 voix de femmes 33 portrait
de femme rosa dès que vous êtes allé
rencontrer dans leur intimité alors il
ya une première série d'entretiens du
même type qui a été porté sur salat
justement au théâtre qu'est ce que vous
en retenez quel homme l humanité c'est
une sorte de cadeau à ce que ce n'était
pas fait pour ça mais que deux
comédiennes jeudi henri chevy gayet se
sont dit que ça pouvait faire un joli
spectacle et qu'effectivement ces
dialogues de femmes que j'essaie
toujours de rendre intemporel
effectivement je n'ai pas envie de
savoir qu'est ce qu'elle pense de
l'actualité forcément ce qui ma terrasse
et comme en ce moment comment ont été
levés quand on est une petite fille à
qui on doit ce regard à que qu'est ce
qui fait qu'on se tient debout comment
est-ce qu'on affronte le deuil et
difficulté les inégalités comment on
arrive à porter sa voix ou ceux réalisés
lorsqu'on a par exemple la veine
artistique ou une envie de politique
toutes ces questions sur qu'est ce que
c'est que le devenir d'une femme et
comment on s'impose dans un monde dont
les règles ont été faites par et pour
les hommes c'est ça que j'ai envie de
savoir écouter de d'entendre ces voix
sur scène que soit gisèle halimi que
soit amélie nothomb christiane taubira
ou bien aux biens nina bouraoui chacune
elle apporte une
sensibilité une force on sent les
dirigeants c'est agréable de les
entendre sur serre si beaucoup à nico
gens d'être venu jusqu'à l'os était
l'invité de paris direct surtout ne
bougez pas l'information internationale
continue